the first thing that was immediate was
really the speed with which things
are done here, best saying the
efficiency of the university
I like all biomedical research what
we spend most of the time is
doing experiments on the bench there is an
experiment that  it took maybe months
to make in brazil when i got here
i only took two to three weeks to
make it so i had a little bit of that
shock of the speed of efficiency but
that soon after i understood that it
is certainly one of the great benefits of
itaqui compared to brazil
so before i came here i lived in são
paulo it is a city of 22 million
inhabitants and one of pramil raven which has
125 thousand inhabitants
the contrast between the two between these
two cities in my head would make
a big difference in being able to
find  nothing in this small town
but I was surprised it's in a
very good way because both the university
counts and the city they
promote  a very diverse cultural and social life
the university has open-door museums
for anyone to have
access to
the music and art departments
are always offering
free shows to the population and even
during summer and spring the city promotes
music festivals  in the center there is
a large park at first
we can feel a cultural difference
but little by little you get used to
this new lifestyle and it is an
excellent opportunity to open
just for me I am having a new
opportunity
a perspective on life beyond of course  of being
able to improve my English
and all this together has been an excellent
experience for my life and for my
professional and personal growth